all I can think about after seeing this
movie is what if characters from this
game crossed with characters from this
game wait a second 90s cameras will
understand this wreck-it Ralph is a
movie that I heard a lot about see a lot
of people were talking about this movie
months ago when the trailer debuted but
I didn't watch it because I've been
trying to stay away from trailers and
everything I was excited for it because
I knew it had something to do with retro
games and that's like awesome to me
because if you can't tell I'm a retro
gamer and this is an animated family
film about this guy wreck-it Ralph he's
the main villain of this game called
fix-it Felix he's the guy who pounds
this building and then fix-it felix
comes in and fixes the building with his
little hammer and everything but he
doesn't want to be the bad guy anymore
he wants to be a good guy he wants to be
that guy who gets the metal who gets the
award who gets all the coins or whatever
he doesn't want to continuously be
loathed as this villain and he wants to
try to find a way to be a good guy so he
sets out on this adventure game jumping
throughout the arcade trying to find an
award that he can win to make himself be
the hero for once he runs into a little
girl who has similar dreams in this game
called sugar rush which looks like a
version of the Katy Perry music video
California girls it's a racing game and
she's a glitch in this game she
apparently wasn't supposed to be there
and everyone looks down at her because
she's a glitch and she was a mistake she
just wants to win a race for one and
they help each other try to reach their
goals I really enjoyed this movie this
movie reminded me a lot of Scott Pilgrim
in a few ways another movie I really
like to see it's different it's it's all
animated but it has that same retro feel
you know you get all those little games
sound effects and everything from the
80s and 90s that you know you just it
brings back so many memories for someone
my age so yeah I grew up with arcade
games and NES games and Super NES and
n64 and everything and those games to me
when I when I see stuff from them in
this movie like there are certain
characters yes there are characters I
won't spoil but there are different
people who show up you're like I know
exactly who that is
holy crap and that's just a really fun
little thing for people like me you know
who grew up with these characters and
everything to see them there but this
movie actually has quite a bit of heart
to it and I was really surprised how
well it was told they didn't just use
the whole retro game thing as a gimmick
or a way to up the nostalgia factor so
to speak they actually used it a lot as
a clever way to propel the story which I
really enjoyed there was a lot of ways
that they used the way these people can
you know they can game jump or they can
go turbo where they leave their game and
they go to another game that try to be a
different character and everything they
travelled through the wires and the
walls to get to these other games they
run into this really awesome chick
voiced by Jane Lynch she's like this
commando in this bug killing game one of
the most important part of any movie but
especially kids movies are the
characters they have to be really
likable and they have to be you know
kind of larger than life and you really
have to start to like these guys in this
movie the characters are great you
really feel for all these people in this
movie I will say though that the little
girl when you first meet her for a while
I was kind of bugged by her she got a
little under my skin until you started
to learn more of her story and I was
like ok I understand I get it now I see
where this is going all in all I had a
lot of fun with wreckit-ralph it was
nostalgic it was a good story it was
heartfelt and I really enjoyed the film
it was a lot of fun I'm gonna give
wreck-it Ralph an a-minus thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
like this review then you can click
right here and get stuck my knives
[Music]